if you manage to snag a huge celebrity
for your project most filmmakers would
take advantage and give them a huge role
but that's not always the case sometimes
people are perfectly happy paying top
dollar to use an ultra star for two
lines or two seconds of screen time as
the old saying goes there are no small
parts only small actors then again some
of these examples are stretch that
expression to its breaking point
here are some major actors hired to do
very little Vin Diesel guardians of the
galaxy Marvel paid The Fast & Furious
star Vin Diesel the whole lot to say
just three words over and over again yes
said that yes he saved it different each
time depending on the situation but he's
still technically repeating three words
for an entire movie and yet each word is
more memorable than anything he said in
the pacifier who the Peter Pan duh dad
just had three times like a kangaroo now
let's all go back to forgetting that
movie exists but to despite the
simplicity of playing Groot
diesel is actually saying something
different each time he has a special
script that gives him the English
translation of whatever Groot is saying
so he can more easily get into the trees
head gun diesel version of the script
except where groups dialogue is not I am
Groot see it's not just a rocket you can
understand him regardless of the work
diesel is or isn't doing with the role
it's still impressive that the actor at
least attempts to do the baby Groot
voice naturally next up voicing all the
Chipmunks in the next inevitable
Alvin sequel or not Jay Leno and George
Clooney South Park these days if South
Park snags a celebrity cameo they'll
likely milk it like any other show would
but that wasn't the case early on and
the hit animated series used to treat
celebrities exactly how you'd expect
them to like they barely exist in one of
the show's first episodes for creators
Trey Parker and Matt Stone somehow
snagged Jay
Leno and they had him play a cat not
like a magical talking cat just the
normal house cat doing mostly normal
house cat things they hired the biggest
talk-show host on the planet to meow a
few times and go home
no Katie this is matcom beef cabbage
look at a bad cake amazingly only a
couple episodes earlier Parker and Stone
caster George Clooney in big gay Al's
big gay boat right Clooney plates and
gay dog who was like well pretty much
any other dog Fergie where'd you get
that pink scarf haha they land two of
the biggest stars in show business and
the South Park guys hired them to sound
like house pets John Hurt Spaceballs
sometimes when you parody something the
thing you're poking fun at gets in on
the act that was the case in 1987 when
actor John Hurt showed up in Mel Brooks
as Spaceballs for about a minute to do
the exact same thing he did in Alien oh
not again
of course we're hurt original alien roll
was the stuff of straight-up nightmares
his time with space balls was a bit more
fun and somewhat less likely to haunt
your dreams until the end of time the
best part about this brief scene is how
the joke works to everybody even if you
never saw alien you can appreciate this
thing popping out of a guy's stomach and
doing its best Michigan J frog
impression
baby my heart on fire if you revealed me
honey you lose me then you'll be left
alone old baby parable and tell me I'm
your cate blanchett hospice actor Cate
Blanchett's a pretty big deal in case
you missed it so it makes perfect sense
to be in a big deal movie like Hot Fuzz
right
what makes less sense however is how she
shows up for less than two minutes never
shows her face never appears again and
never gets credited for her role despite
that role being that of the main
characters estranged girlfriend I know I
know I know
hi Blanche it's Jeanine is a crime scene
investigator clad head-to-toe in a white
examiner suit which leaves for the
wonderful scene where Simon Pegg starts
talking to her only to realize he's
talking to the wrong person in a white
suit Jeanine I've been transferred I'm
moving away for a while well not Jeanine
okay Janine I've been transferred I'm
moving away for a while he in the Rio
Janine have an argument about a pegs
character being a workaholic and that's
it that's all Cate Blanchett did in this
film but since the scene was so
delightful and delightfully British it's
also all she needed to do Kurt Russell
Forrest Gump one of the first famous
people young the Forrest Gump from
England with was a pre Fame Elvis
Presley at the time he was just some
southern kid with a guitar but though
Forrest did accidentally teach the King
his signature dance move I started
moving around music
swinging in my hear the guy physically
playing Elvis is just some guy but the
voice has none other than Kurt Russell
who showed up to sing a little bit of
hound dog in the voice-over booth I like
that guitar it sounded good
voicing Elvis was in a way you're taking
it full circle for Russell 15 years
before Forrest Gump
he played Elvis and a movie called
appropriately enough Elvis the movie but
he didn't actually get to sing country
star Ronnie McDowell handled that well
it's a thanks to Forrest Russell can
finally say he played the Elvis role
completely it just took him a while to
get there Brad Pitt and Matt Damon
confessions of a dangerous mind based on
the not true story of dating game
creator Chuck Barris being a CIA
assassin confessions of a dangerous mind
sported an all-star director in George
Clooney he naturally used his star power
to bring in fellow superstars such as
Matt Damon and Brad Pitt and to
naturally have them do well pretty much
nothing literally the only time you see
Damon or Pitt is when they appear on
Barris this dating game they never say
anything and they never even attempt to
woo the girl they just sit there as the
camera quickly planned to cut them
that's all you barely have enough time
to process the fact that two of the
biggest stars on the planet or playing
the equivalent of movie extras finally
the camera focuses on bachelor number
three ash lovely guy who inexplicably
wins anyway beating out his two gorgeous
contestants still the audience getting
to see the two of the top actors in the
world for a whopping 10 seconds only to
never see them again
is a bigger punchline than all of Barris
insane stories combined Glenn Close book
don't feel bad there's a good chance you
didn't notice Glenn Close that hook at
all
but there she is playing one of Captain
Hook's many underling pirates but no
matter how much you pause and stare at
the screen to catch a tiny glimpse of
close in the crowd you won't find her
that's because she's not in the crowd
instead she's the bearded pirate getting
brutally punished for betting against
hook
it's amazing what happens when you put
down the razor for a few days yes
that's close playing a bearded male
pirate named gutless sporting man Leah
whiskers and pretty much any guy could
ever hope to grow living up to his name
gutless immediately starts groveling and
crying when he realizes that hook-nosed
he's a traitor yes you made a fool he's
then tossed into the food box a treasure
chest that the other Pirates throw live
scorpion bin sir and so gutless
apparently dies from being scorpion to
death dan Aykroyd Indiana Jones on the
Temple of Doom Dan Aykroyd has one of
the more distinct voices in Hollywood we
used to roast Stay Puft Marshmallow by
the fire careful conduct so it's a
shocker that he was actually able to
pull off an uncredited cameo and have so
few people realize it with him and yet
he did just that with Indiana Jones and
the Temple of Doom he's a guy escorting
Indy and his gal pal along with short
round onto a plane all while apologizing
that they'll have to ride with a bunch
of chickens in the 15 or so seconds you
see Aykroyd on screen you never actually
see his face close-up which explains a
lot of why his cameo when so under the
radar for viewers I'm all about I fought
with your system so we managed to secure
free Michael Bay mystery men well he's
not an actor per se Michael Bay is as
famous as anyone he directs and whenever
he insists his movies are actually good
we're forced to suspend disbelief more
than we do whenever Tom Hanks plays a
mean guy
seriously we're just not buying a Tom
got they managed to get himself in front
of the camera a while back or beat
briefly if you watch the Ben Stiller's
1999 superhero spoof a mystery man and
the judging by the box office cake not
many of you did you would have seen
Michael Bay for a glorious four seconds
he's the frackie doofus bro at the evil
guys meeting and that's basically it
he doesn't even come back to hit Ben
Stiller in the head with an evil via cam
really if you think about it it's
absolutely perfect that they played a
frat guy that is after all its target
demographic
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love tea
[Music]